[music] Even the
stars are trained and lose the mortal battle dollar Because I
never talked about myself, my
career was like this
Mitsuko, the dog of the castle,
just one
more thing Come in, yeah, yeah,
in 4 Barry's money is certainly
associated with noble strokes, but
even if he says it's from Motomura, I'll do something about it Now it's
too fast  Nishiichiri is such a pottery
Ah, the art of changing Cries and feelings I
just raise my voice or caress with the wind that blows The
story is about when the three of us traveled together before becoming famous as heroes
A remote village  When he stopped at the village,
he heard that a beautiful half-
elf had been chosen as a sacrifice.
If so, is there a slight difference in personalities?